[Musique]
j'ai passé deux années merveilleuses au
yémen de 2006 à 2008
j'ai pu sillonner le pays des montagnes
de manara ovale et de l'hadramout des
palais de seyoun à l'île de socotra j'ai
découvert une culture un héritage des
pratiques un petit peu particulières
comme le khat cette plante euphorisante
que les hommes et les femmes match à
longueur de journée et qui donne
l'impression d'avoir une balle de golf
coincé juste derrière la joue si je suis
parti au yémen c'est d'abord pour
travailler travailler dans une société
qui faisait des services sur téléphone
mobile
il faut bien avoir en tête qu'au yémen
à cette époque là le développement du
mobile est largement supérieur au
développement de l'électricité ou même
de l'eau potable
c'est donc un atout majeur pour la
diffusion des services notre service
phare était un service de chat par sms
je sais pas si vous pouvez mesurer la
rupture sociale de la fourniture d'un
service comme celui ci dans un pays
comme le yémen qu'est ce que ça signifie
de pouvoir chatter par sms ça veut dire
que soudainement les hommes et les
femmes vont pouvoir échanger partager
dans une sphère publique ou les hommes
et les femmes sont séparés dans les
transports dans les restaurants à la
mosquée dans les magasins garantir le
succès de ce service
c'était une mission génial je me suis
littéralement éclaté je suis arrivé
j'étais manager d'une équipe 2-1 et
j'avais pour mission de développer ce
service c'est à dire faire plus de
trafic augmenter le trafique ça veut
dire augmenter le nombre de
fonctionnalités dans le service installé
de nouveaux serveurs
installer de nouvelles machines générer
plus de revenus et donc pouvoir
développer d'autres services recruter
plus de personnes mon équipe a grandi et
au bout d'un moment
à force de responsabilité d'astreinte
je vais arriver un petit peu au bord au
bord d'une rupture puisque je n'arrivais
plus à assumer toutes les
responsabilités qui m'avait été confiée
est donc fait quelques recherches sur
internet pour voir si j'étais tout seul
dans ce cas là je suis tombé sur un
livre blanc scrum et xp
depuis les tranchées un petit guide
écrit par enrique nyberg qui nous
explique la méthode scrum et d'autres
outils la méthode scrum en gros c'est
simple pour partir et créer un produit
on va organiser ça dans un backlog un
backlog produit dans lequel on va mettre
tout ce qu'on veut faire
ce backlog produit sera géré par un
producteur et la vie en scrum est
organisée en itération des itérations
qui ont duré fixe et constante
par exemple deux semaines toutes les
itérations permettent de livrer un
incrément de produits c'est un crémant
de produits a été le fruit d'une
succession d'événements qui sont
toujours les mêmes dans une libération
on va d'abord planifié l'itération
producteurs et équipe de réalisateurs
c'est à dire ceux qui ont la compétence
technique
tous les joueurs ces gens s'organisent
dans un délit meeting nos réunions de
synchronisation quotidienne à chaque fin
d'itérations on démontre ce qui a été
produit lors d'une revue d'itérations et
l'équipe améliore son processus et son
procédé lors de ce qu'on appelle une
rétrospective et parce que ce mode de
fonctionnement est compliqué il y à un
acteur particulier qui s'appelle le
scrum master qui a pour charge pour
mission d'assurer que ce mode de
fonctionnement est bien exécuté ça nous
a permis de radicalement transformé
notre façon de produire on a pu inviter
des gens qui ne venaient jamais voir ce
que les techniciens faisait on a pu
capter de nouvelles idées et moi en tant
que manager ça m'a permis d'aborder une
rupture
je n'avais pas du tout anticipé une
rupture managériale celle de
l'apprentissage de la délégation
je me suis rendu compte que j'étais dans
une modalité managériale descendante
c'est à dire moi je décide
moi je fais est soudainement je
proposais une modalité managériale
circulaire où tout le monde est sur le
même pied d'égalité
j'ai vu un très grand intérêt mais pour
mes équipiers yéménites qui ont plutôt
une histoire et une culture tribale
non pas forcément accueilli cette
délégation avec le même esprit positif
que j'avais la situation géopolitique se
dégradant je suis rentré en france et
dans la nouvelle mission que j'ai
accepté je me suis intéressé de plus
près à cette notion d'agilité à
l'historique je suis tombé sur un
déliverable majeur de l'agilité qui
s'appelle le manifeste pour le
développement agile de logiciels et donc
compris que l'agilité c'est d'abord une
histoire d'informaticiens ce qui est
d'ailleurs un des principal défaut et si
vous remplacez le terme logiciel par
produit ce manifeste agile
dès lors peut s'adresser à n'importe
quelle industrie
ce manifeste nous propose un recueil de
quatre valeurs et douze principes qui
forment un cadre en substance l'agilité
c'est une équipe qui va apprendre à
livrer de la valeur à ses utilisateurs
qui va s'améliorer en continu le plus
simplement du monde
et lorsqu'on exposé ces sujets là
lorsque j'en parle avec les équipes se
demande bien où peut être la rupture
puisque finalement ce n'est que du bon
sens pourtant le bon sens cette rupture
là elle est bel et bien devant nous si
on regarde un petit peu plus près
comment est-ce que nous organisons la
façon dont nous produisons les services
les projets les produits on part d'une
idée qui devrait se concrétiser et nous
allons dès qu'on pose est bien souvent
fractionner les différentes étapes pour
pouvoir aboutir à notre livrables final
une pensée linéaire séquentielle procédé
simple facile à piloter facile à
organiser qui souffre néanmoins d'un
seul défaut c'est le changement
un environnement simple c'est d'abord un
environnement dans lequel je sais ce que
je fais je sais ce que je veux je
maîtrise mon besoin je maîtrise la
dimension métier et je sais comment je
vais le faire je maîtrise les aspects
techniques dès lors une pensée linéaire
simple des composés est tout à fait
adapté dans un environnement comme celui
ci je maîtrise aussi l inverse
je ne maîtrise pas vraiment ce que je
veux faire si je ne sais pas tout à fait
ce que je veux évoluer dans un
environnement chaotique les pensée
linéaire vont mettre ces environnements
là sous tension heureusement ou
malheureusement pour nous le changement
fait partie du quotidien et qui produit
un certain nombre de variabilité qui
nous amène à envisager des choses plutôt
de manière complexe et nous sommes de
plus en plus face à ces environnements
dits complexes et c'est bien ça que
réponse est agitée c'est cette rupture
c'est de partir cette fois ci toujours
d'une idée mais de travailler vers le
besoin des utilisateurs ce qui change
radicalement la façon de penser et pour
y parvenir on va procéder par itérations
à chaque itération on va livrer un petit
bout un petit bout de produits que je
vais montrer à mes utilisateurs
ce petit bout de produits en le livrant
eh bien on va pouvoir me faire des
retours dessus ce qu'on va appeler des
feedbacks certains seront positifs
d'autres négatifs et donc c'est bien
principe d'essais et d'erreurs que je
suis en train d'exposer plus j'échoue
plus je teste plus augmente la
probabilité des choux et plus augmente
la probabilité d'erreur plus augmente la
probabilité de réussir dès lors ce
principe itératif devient le moteur de
l'apprentissage et au delà du procédé
au delà du processus pour pouvoir
acquérir les bénéfices de cette démarche
là c'est avant tout au niveau de
l'équipe que ça va se situer et c'est
bien ça l'enjeu de la transformation de
l'agilité c'est d'amener des équipes à
qui on va donner de nouvelles
prérogatives pour qu'elles développent
leurs performances on
elles vont être auto organisés
autodéterminé bruce stockman dans son
modèle de formation des équipes nous
explique comment une équipe
quels sont les phases qu'une équipe va
suivre on va d'abord former l'équipe
cette phase de formation de l'équipe
consiste à mettre des gens ensemble ils
vont être autocentré d'avoir pensé à eux
mêmes ceux qui ont formé l'équipe ours
attendent vont s'attendre à ce qu'elle
soit performante face de performing
c'est à dire des gens aligné sur
l'ensemble des objectifs et qui sait
travailler de concert dans la
performance
évidemment il ya des étapes
intermédiaires après l'étape de forming
une équipe va certainement vivre une
effet qu'une une phase de storming
storming de tension ou là je vais
prendre conscience de l'objectif
collectif et des règles communes des
compromis que je vais devoir faire cette
phase de conflits scène peut parfois
amener à la destruction d'une équipe qui
allait mal conduite
lorsqu individuellement on accepte de
faire des compromis
lorsqu individuellement on accepte
l'écoutent au sein de son équipe
on va pouvoir commencer à rentrer dans
une phase de normalisation une phase de
normes hing la normalisation permet de
créer des règles d'équipé qui pratiquait
régulièrement vont pouvoir nous
permettre d'obtenir la phase ii
performing talkman décrit une cinquième
équipe une cinquième étape à jour ning
qui consiste quand la destruction de
l'équipe la dissolution de l'équipe
notamment lorsque nous sommes en phase
projet donné la responsabilité à une
équipe lui donner la possibilité de
s'autodéterminer
souvent ça va être nouveau et une équipe
évolue rarement en autarcie allait
toujours au contact d'autres acteurs
dans les organisations une équipe est
souvent supervisé
qu'est-ce que je deviens moi en tant que
manager face à une équipe qui s'auto
détermine qui définit son plan d'action
qui dit là où elle va aller quel est mon
rôle est
dans les ressources humaines ça veut
dire quoi avoir une équipe à prenantes
comment est-ce que je travaille avec ces
nouveaux profils ces nouveaux parcours
d'évolution de compétences comprend dès
lors que l'arrivée de l'agilité dans les
organisations et plus simplement une
histoire de processus
c'est plus qu'une rupture locale c'est
une rupture dites systémiques et la
transformation des systèmes
on sait aujourd'hui comment ça
fonctionne virginia satire
psychothérapeute américaine dans les
années 70 a posé les bases des démarches
d'accompagnement au changement
comprendre un système c'est déjà
comprendre que tout système se trouve
d'abord dans un statu quo il est bien
pas bien c'est un niveau de performance
ce statu quo va être perturbée par un
événement externe par exemple
l'introduction de l'agilité et les
systèmes vont réagir mécaniquement en
résistant on parle aussi domeo stasi
c'est à dire la capacité d'un système
qu'il va avoir à ne pas changer les
conditions de son état de son statu quo
pour obtenir un nouvel état de
performances un autre statut quo car
chacun l'aura anticipé la joue et
l'introduction d'un phénomène externe
pas créer une perte de repères qui va
nous amener dans un état le plus bas
étant la vallée du désespoir
je sais ce que j'ai perdu nous savons ce
que nous avons perdu mais nous avons
mais nous n'avons pas encore reconstruit
les étapes de cette nouvelle performance
quand j'explique ces sujets et ses
concepts dans les organisations peut y
avoir un côté particulièrement
vertigineux un devis individuellement et
collectivement
c'est pour ça qu'à bord dé la notion
d'agilité est associé à une rupture
pédagogique une rupture pédagogique
c'est d'envisager qu'aujourd'hui et puis
simplement les approche descendante
on peut faire beaucoup de choses pour
que ces personnes qui constituent les
systèmes se saisisse de ces sujets
qu'elle comprenne qu'elle apprenne va
utiliser énormément de jeux de
simulation utilisées
des pédagogies visuel comme la
facilitation graphique ce que je suis en
train de faire est d'utiliser des
pédagogies verbal par exemple inspiré du
coaching des pédagogies inversée
technique de questionnements pour que
les individus se saisissent eux mêmes de
leur sujet et s'autodéterminer il est
intéressant de voir que cette rupture
pédagogique n'est pas seulement en
marche dans les organisations
mais elle est également présente depuis
quasiment une dizaine d'années dans
toutes les écoles
quasiment dans tous les parcours
universitaires et quand on sait combien
il est difficile de faire évoluer les
parcours universitaires est intéressant
de se questionner pourquoi ce module
d'agilité aujourd'hui est enseignée
peut-être parce qu'il y avait un creux
les aide parce qu'il y avait un trou à
combler ce trou c'est l'apprentissage dû
travailler ensemble l'apprentissage du
travail collectif le travail collectif
c'est d'abord respecter le bien-être
établir un cadre bienveillant pour soi
et pour les autres de ce cadre
bienveillant apprendre à développer de
la valeur ensemble tout en recherchant
notre performance
si vous voulez commencer votre chemin
pour l'agilité je vous propose quatre
outils qui ne coûte rien la première
première chose vous pouvez vous
interroger sur la définition de terminer
lorsque vous formulez un besoin une
exigence comment apporterez vous la
preuve que ce que vous demandez sera
bien terminé quels sont les tests que
vous voudrez observé mettez en place un
outil qu'on va appeler de management
visuel avec trois colonnes affaires en
cours et terminer dans chacune des
colonnes météo temps de post-it qu'il
faut qu'ils vont représenter
les tâches de votre équipe
quotidiennement vous verrez les progrès
que vous faites et vous aurez une
lecture
systémique du travail de l'équipe tous
les jours fait une réunion de
synchronisation de 15 minutes pour
parler des travaux exécutés ensemble et
à faire aujourd'hui et dernière pratique
facile à mettre en place des marais les
rétrospectives les rétrospectives sait
faire l'analyse
en une heure toutes les semaines tous
les quinze jours de ce qui va bien de ce
qui va moins bien et des actions
d'amélioration pour votre équipe
l'agilité c'est tout ça c'est une
succession de ruptures qui mises
bout-à-bout vont vous permettre de
remettre votre équipe et votre
organisation en mouvement je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]